baseball has started to publish some of
its rules for the season that is due to
begin late next month they're gonna test
players every other day saliva tests
every other day temperature tech checks
twice per day and a lot of things that
will look very different than what we're
used to seeing from baseball no spitting
which automatically will be very
different than what we're used to seeing
in baseball that'll be hard
yeah yeah no you can't go to the umpire
to argue you know fighting fighting will
be strictly dealt with there and see
that then see that's the difference
between baseball and football a lot of
the things that that would make baseball
kind of look like football you're not
gonna be allowed to do you can't you
don't know you know high fives no fist
bumps none of that stuff everybody's
gonna be in their own little their own
little cocoon walking around the field
and you bring your own equipment I mean
it's just things that aren't going to be
practical in football but it shows you
the extreme measures that need to be
taken to minimize the spread of the
virus and it just it doesn't make me
more optimistic that's gonna work for
football because ultimately you got to
get 22 guys out on the football field
playing football which means being in
close contact and the league is betting
on its assessment being accurate Cris
that outdoors open spaces will result in
fewer infections and if they can keep
anyone off the field who may be infected
that's going to keep it at a minimum as
well but we'll just see they got to be
they gonna be they had do everything
they can to minimize the potential for
an outbreak and then they got to be
ready to pivot and activate a plan if
there is an outbreak and those are two I
think Herculean tasks I just wonder if
the NFL is gonna try to implement some
of these rules too like are they gonna
tell quarterbacks they can't lick their
hands this year you know right away I
think of like the great Drew Brees right
I mean every after every throw it's lick
lick pull his shoulder pads down you
know that would be a game-changer for
some quarterbacks that's part of their
their tick or what you know their
process between plays and a lot of guys
really want to lick their fingers just
like baseball pitchers because yeah it
gives you a little moisture on what can
be a slick leather
all at times to make the grip better so
I just never I'd be curious to know if
the NFL I don't see why that would
matter in football you know when the
play before maybe von Miller hits Drew
Brees from behind and is breathing and
sweating on them to where I want to go
who cares if you lick the football at
this point the guy just bled on his face
or whatever but yeah I'll just be I'd be
interested to see if that happens and
you know the other thing Mike
just real quick out of all the college
athletes and the players so far and I
don't want to I'm not trying to be
insensitive have you heard of one that's
how to really deal with the co
mid-nineteen in a horrible way yeah yeah
yeah
Tony Paz Ali's son got extremely sick
from it it's Ali who's a good one
Florida State the bigger they are yeah
you've got guys who are heavy and yeah
just just don't assume any we Hill
graders you got a greater chance to die
in a car on the way to school well okay
fine but this is still an extra chance
of dying that you otherwise wouldn't
have and tell that to the family of the
one kid who does die because of this so
anyway not an easy situation let's hope
that the people at the NFL are paying
the proper attention to that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports